la situación esa población en el centro
del Don Vázquez viene siendo el gran
objetivo de las fuerzas rusas desde hace
meses especialmente desde el verano
cambia no solamente con las horas sino
también con los días desde el pasado
sábado los enfrentamientos se hicieron
mayores Incluso en algún momento se
llegó a pensar que las tropas ucranianas
iban a retirarse para reagruparse A las
afueras de la ciudad y volver a hacer
una contraofensiva pues Anoche habló la
viceministra de defensa y dijo que en
ningún momento se iban a retirar y que
esto era una decisión militar y no una
decisión política y esta mañana también
habló el portavoz de las fuerzas
militares de la región del Don vas y
habló de que se estaban mandando
refuerzos nosotros estamos en la
población de Constantino kauna población
estratégica en esta región del capaz
especialmente donde llega toda la
logística Para apoyar a baku y hemos
visto como si han llegado algunos
refuerzos militares que que van hacia
adentro ayudar a quienes están peleando
y sosteniendo la ciudad pero también
hacer recambio porque hay muchos de los
soldados que están adentro están
exhaustos nosotros esta mañana estuvimos
algunas de las poblaciones del
noroccidente son poblaciones todavía en
control de los ucranianos que están
buscando ser tomadas por los rusos para
acercar a bacmut y lo que vemos es que
las batallas es bastante intensas son
pequeñas poblaciones No quedan sino
prácticamente muy pocos civiles
militares que sostienen y hay ataques de
un lado y de otro y sigue siendo
solamente una ruta de acceso a mudo y
prohibían que los civiles o los
voluntarios llegaran a la ciudad
solamente los militares pueden acceder
allí pero también nos dicen que la
situación si bien estuvo muy difícil en
los días pasados vuelve a estar un poco
a favor de los ucranianos en las últimas
horas especialmente desde anoche que la
situación está un poco mejor y más
calmada sin embargo Todas estas son
versiones dadas por los militares que
llegan hasta aquí hasta Constantinopla y
muchas de ellas son algunos hablan de
que es mejor otros hablan de que sigue
estando crítica Así que siguen siendo
versiones muy contradictorias y muy
difíciles para entender realmente la
situación en